[Music]
foreign
let's go ahead and open up the door if
you could please hello everybody Welcome
to daily with Doc my name is Becca dukes
and I am honored to have you take the
time investing time in yourself with us
so here on daily with Doc we provide
empowering information that puts into
your hands and into your toolbox
information that you can do on your own
to help yourself especially when the
doctors can't find anything wrong with
you folks
okay I can't go there but anyways you
are in for a treat because we are not
chemical deficient we are nutrient
deficient and when the body is no longer
nutrient deficient there's a lot of
things that the body can do
unexplainably because of the science of
epigenetics and we are honored to have
one of the founding fathers of that
science of epigenetics here to guide us
as we are all searching for answers
folks there's so many things that we've
been told that are untrue incorrect
and we don't have to mask symptoms to
get through life we can actually give
the body what it needs so the body can
do what it's designed to do so that it
can function the way it's designed to
function and
we can Thrive instead of barely survive
and that's what you're going to learn
about today on
daily with Doc if you are out on any of
the platforms hello drop us a line drop
us off hello let us know where you are
joining us from if you're on the replay
type in there replay and where you're
joining us from and if you're here live
with us go ahead and put in the chat let
us know where you're joining us from as
well we'd love to see this the reach of
our program as we as individuals can
only do so much but when we work
together as a community and we share
information we can make a greater impact
a positive impact on our communities and
our world so thank you so much for doing
all of that and as a thank you for doing
that we do have a giveaway that you can
sign up for first and then do your
sharing go to
dwdgiveaway.com and sign up for our our
giveaway
where I'm going to be saying thank you
to the individuals who who share the
most because you are helping us make
that greater impact that we are looking
for now
if you're here live with us because
you're on the screen if you're here live
with us and you'd like to ask a question
go ahead and raise your hand I will be
calling upon the individuals with their
hands up if you would rather just put it
into the chat make sure and this is a
chat for anywhere make sure that you are
including age weight height if you have
any conditions that you are on a
pharmaceutical for because just because
you're not having those symptoms and
they're being masked by a pharmaceutical
does not mean that you do not have those
issues anymore so we look at the body as
a whole that is what Dr Wallach has
found to be the fact that
everything is connected so if you've got
something going on in one place chances
are it's going on in other places too
it's just that one spot is where you're
feeling it or
having that
um discomfort sensation
dysfunction type stuff going on whether
it's pain or not if there's dysfunction
most of the time it's because of
nutritional deficiencies somewhere
within your diet and folks are food it
just does not have it
so without that I just are with that
I just have to let you know the FDA
requires us to let you know actually
that this program is not meant to take
the place of your primary care physician
it is not meant to and that the products
are not meant to treat diagnose or cure
any diseases but folks when you give the
body what it needs
as proven in the science of epigenetics
your body can do some amazing things and
to help
share with us more about what the body
does and how nutrition plays into it I
think we're going to be talking about
the skin and acne and hormones and all
types of stuff folks so you're in for a
treat listen up get ready to take notes
and the nice thing about it Dr Wallach
did you know that we have the replays
for this program on daily withdoc.com
we also have your good foods bad foods
list on daily withdoc.com we also have a
store that offers the products that Dr
Wallach is going to mention and what to
take and even a section that teach that
shares with you how to take it so Dr
Wallach
for those that don't know you
you have a Bachelor of Science in
agriculture and soil you have a doctor
of veterinary medicine you have three
post doctorates of or in pathology
you've taught nutrition at the college
level
because of your findings you were fired
so he went back to become a naturopathic
physician and it's not the findings it
was actually the you being fired
is what got you into teaching nutrition
and then to become a naturopathic
physician do I got the order right there
that's correct
so what about nutrition Dr Wallach
really impacts or plays into how our
body and our skin is going to function
okay well any living thing requires
nutrition whether you're a plant or a
worm or a virus a human being an
elephant a whale fish everything that
lives requires nutrition to function
just like your car requires gasoline oil
brake fluid food for your transmission a
coolant and your radiator all these
things are required so that everything
works correctly and and so forth and and
human beings are no different okay and
um
one of the mysterious things is up until
three o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882
most people didn't think about running
to the store and buying vitamins and
minerals okay and
1882 okay
and prior to that we're getting our
minerals which make up two-thirds of the
90th Century nutrients
because we used wood is fuel we use
polish fuel we would take the wood ashes
and coal ashes and put them into our
Gardens and our fields and wood ashes
and coal ashes were like 95 or more
minerals
and only two or three percent carbon
okay well once we went to electricity at
three o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882
suddenly now all around the world within
weeks within weeks when electricity came
out it was such a fascinating thing the
whole world just flipped over to
electricity
and we gave up our source of minerals
that we'd had for three thousand to five
thousand years we have all these
diseases and all these terrible things
happening and people say well you know
we never had this before what is this
well it's because you were getting your
your mineral nutrients from the wood
ashes and coal ashes for three thousand
to five thousand years when he went to
electricity that all went away okay and
doctors still haven't figured that out
and so
that's why we came out with the book
um the let's see here Hell's Kitchen
Hell's Kitchen the book is the
transition from wooden coal as fuel to
electricity now there's electricity
isn't that the bad guy it's just a tool
okay but it's people not knowing what
they gave up was a problem
they didn't realize for three thousand
five thousand years they were getting
these minerals was good for our joints
and our skin and our livers and our
hearts and our bone marrow and all this
kind of stuff well once we went to
electricity that all went away
and nobody paying attention to that
particularly doctors oh just eat well
you get you've all heard that oh Jay Z
alligators you need don't waste your
money on vitamins and minerals well we
didn't have to buy vitamins and minerals
all those years for three thousand five
thousand years because we're using wood
and coal of fuel we're using the wood
ashes of coal ash this is a fertilizer
and also as a spice in our Foods getting
our minerals that way once we went to
electricity
that all went away
okay and we're still suffering from that
ignorance I'm going to talk about people
being stupid it's an ignorance for lack
of information okay so that's why we
wrote the book Hell's Kitchen so you
know the transition okay and of course
it's one of those things where we're
still fighting that transition because
doctors are still telling their patients
oh just eat well you did everything you
need don't waste your money and buy them
some animals and so they contribute to
the disaster by saying that okay
doctors like to give drugs to
um giving the patient instant results
you know something like cortisone
prednisone painkillers oh man I had this
terrible pain in my joint my knee
for years and the doctor just gave me
this wonderful injection I could give
myself two three times a day and I mean
the pain go away in three minutes
and it was just wonderful
well
when you get rid of pain with a
painkiller
that doesn't solve the problem it's just
temporarily eliminates a symptom
okay and this is what's going on here
and so
when we talk about what's going on here
in today's system
and let's look at
the lack of nutrition and we have
arthritis osteoporosis we have skin
problems eggs which we're going to talk
about today eczema dermatitis alopecia
which is hair loss
um yet psoriasis eczema dermatitis
um let's see here every kind of skin as
you can think of is due to nutritional
deficiency
acne okay acne is due to a nutritional
deficiency and of course it's on the
face because we have a lot of skin
glands in this in the skin in the face
and the scalp and so horse for for
lubrication and and so forth because the
hair is growing and there's hair
follicles and all this kind of stuff
and so it's one of those things where
acne and of course when you're going
through puberty
um there's hormones involved here and
your the hormones are telling you to
grow faster and and um so forth and if
you don't have the nutrients
to keep up with this fast growth you
start getting symptoms like acne you
have pimples and infections on your face
and and neck and head you lose your hair
and all those kind of stuff these are
all just simple nutritional deficiency
diseases okay and so this is one of the
things
um we actually have a program you know
the 90 essential nutrients give it all
the bad foods maximize absorption
and then I'm going to make sure that
you're taking things like the hair skin
and nails hair skin and Nails the name
of the product tells you what what part
of your body it works on air skin Oh
skin oh there you go and nails
and so it's one of those things where
this is not difficult but you do have to
play the game so to speak and within the
parameters of the body's needs when you
give the body what it needs the body has
a remarkable ability
to heal and maintain itself including
the skin remember your skin covers your
entire body
from head to toe from shoulder to
shoulder from hip to hip
toes fingers back arms legs bottom every
place you as exposed to the to the
outside has a skin
okay so obviously we need a lot of stuff
to make the skin happy requires 90
essential nutrients 60 Minutes 16
vitamins 12 minutes and Three fatty
acids and if one of those 90 is missing
you're going to get a skin symptom okay
and so your skin is a very very good
barometer at telling you is what's going
on inside your body
and your skin can recover very quickly
you give it the right raw materials and
give her the bad stuff so you can absorb
it okay and a lot of times you may be
doing everything right on a sort of 90
of the time but if you're eating the bad
stuff so you cannot absorb this stuff
and it's all going in your mouth because
it's all coming out the other end so the
septic tank is happy but you're not
happy okay
and so again this is something that's
very simple
and some of the more primitive
uh countries okay as opposed to the
highly developed countries
don't have the problems because they're
still using wood and coal as fuel and
they're still using wooden coal ashes as
per their spices and their food and also
in their Gardens and their fields as a
fertilizer and they're getting their
minerals that way and that's why people
say what how do these people in the hunt
you know in the Himalayan Mountains
their life expectancy is 120.
okay our life expectancy right now is 76
okay and
they're 120
they don't even have medical doctors
okay so it's because we're missing the
nutrients your skin needs a lot of
nutrition because it's it's separating
you from the outside world protecting
you from heat protecting you from cold
protecting you from wind and and all
kinds of parasites and viruses and bugs
of all kinds I like the
colloidal silver there's no alcohol in
you can spray it on your skin you can
spray it in an open wound there's no no
alcohol it won't burn
and
it will help you
fend off bugs that like to eat your skin
okay it's a little silver and I use a
lot of that because I get visited by so
many people from all over the world and
they want to shake hands and give you a
hug and all that kind of stuff
and so
um I'm protecting Myself by using the
colloidal silver
when I wake up say five or ten minutes
before breakfast five or ten minutes for
lunch five or ten minutes for dinner
time and five or ten minutes before
bedtime okay now you have to appreciate
the little silver kills viruses bacteria
fungus and yeast
which you know gets you in your skin
well guess what
um the
the whole idea here is
the penicillin only kills
and see here what is it um
penicillin kills two different types of
bacteria okay they're both gram-positive
okay and we're talking about
um what streptococcus and staphylococcus
whereas silver kills all viruses
bacteria fungus and yeast which one's
better for you penicillin
okay r o
colloidal silver
well Dr Wallach how about vitiligo
okay well Vitiligo is a loss of pigment
okay and to make pigment
um regardless what race you are to to
make pigment your skin requires
raw materials and nutrients to do that
okay and if you're missing them
or you can't absorb them because you're
eating gluten we'd run around oats and
drinking carbonated water and that sort
of stuff so it can't absorb minerals and
digest food
um you're going to have
Vitiligo is one of the symptoms you can
have is a loss of skin color and hair
color you know when you see somebody you
know has Snow White hair and there's 30
40 50 years old
um that has nothing to do with age has
to do with a nutritional deficiency and
without those nutrients the skin might
be able to make hair but it can't make
the pigment that gives color to the hair
okay
how about like babies that are born with
vitiligo
um is that something that that is a
nutrient deficiency
while it's developing stuff my mother
was missing stuff early in pregnancy
when the skin was forming in the embryo
okay and so the baby is paying the price
because mother
was maybe eating wheat bread around oats
um and even if she was supplementing is
it all comes out the other end because
you cannot absorb if you're eating wheat
bread around oats or if you're not
and we brought around oats but you're
still not getting all the nutrients for
a variety of reasons
babies can be born
you know there are babies that belong to
the black community or born white okay
say they don't have enough of the skin
pigment generating
equipment working properly
all right well something that's that's
very common and I I get this question a
lot has to do with teenagers and acne
so I they've got so many different types
of acne or acne that they've added an
extra word to
um so when kids are going through
puberty
and they start getting these outbreaks
is that solely nutrition or does that
have to deal with also some type of the
hormone hormone changes that are going
on
well the hormone changes Drive
the rate of growth and okay and so when
your hormones are driving growth the
more growth you have the more nutrition
you need
okay okay that kind of makes sense
yeah so um how about I've heard one
theory that when you have acne outbreaks
it's toxins trying to get out through
your skin
is there any truth to that
well that belongs to a science called
crapola
okay okay so when you have acne this has
to do with hormones hormones are very
high and it tells your skin to do things
and if it doesn't have all the right raw
materials and everything to do
everything just right
you you get a collection of worrisome
um things going on in your skin and Acme
is one of them again because your face
tends to be oily because of the hair on
top of your head and that kind of stuff
and so this is why
um you get Acme mostly on the face okay
uh
in the side of your head and neck and
that kind of thing because your body's
growing and if you don't have all the
right equipment it's just like your car
It's Made To Go
50 60 70 miles an hour but if you don't
have oil in it it's going to burn up
right well and I know some acne gets to
where it's like on the back and causes
scarring on the all over is there
anything that can be done Dr Wallach to
to support the skin
um
after that scarring has occurred
well the skin is constantly
renewing itself and in some cases you
get 50 Improvement 25 Improvement
uh you can't guarantee 100 Improvement
um you know we have people who have Snow
White hair and they're really working on
their skin and their diet and supplement
program and they get a little bit of
hair color coming in
but not entirely all over and that's
because they still have some injury in
their intestines they may only be
absorbing
two percent or five percent or ten
percent of what's needed to manage the
skin and the hair and all this kind of
stuff it's not that you're not taking it
in but you still have all these injuries
for many many years of
um incorrect diet and that kind of thing
right or you know you've got
Pharmaceuticals that kill off the stuff
inside that's supposed to be there and
and cause damage
um so I love the fact Dr Wallach that
the body is continually regenerating
cells continually trying to to grow in a
positive way to keep everything
functioning properly well let me let me
just jump in here for a minute now do
you know why doctors like to be
dermatologists
I have never been asked that question
before no I don't okay
well
each year in America just to treat the
symptoms of things going on in the skin
weird things going on the skin we spend
75 billion dollars a year just to treat
the skin
wow
that's crazy does that include Cosmetics
no that has nothing with Cosmetics this
is just
cortisone prednisone that kind of stuff
okay
um
uh and you know there's a lot of things
that dermatologists use they're not
we're not talking about Cosmetics okay
we're talking about hormones we're
talking about drugs all these kind of
things just to treat the symptoms of
skin issues just to treat the symptoms
of skin issues
75 billion dollars a year
is probably a skin doctor probably a
dermatologist
so you mentioned Cortisone and
prednisone those are both steroids if
I'm not mistaken that's correct and on a
steroid that blocks the body's natural
immune response
so you're you're like putting with those
you're putting like you know electrical
tape over the red warning light on the
dash so that you really can't see it but
it's not really taking care of the issue
or the underlying cause is it
is correct it's the same principle
you're getting you know prescriptions
for
um these various drugs that give you you
know within myths the itching and the
burning pain go away
uh that's problematic over the Long Haul
because you're really not getting to the
basic root cause of the problem is that
approach is just treating the symptoms
right
whether it's it's an internal treatment
or an external topical that's correct
all right so Dr Wallach
let's let's take a teenage kid let's say
17 year old boy
um who has acne
what would you recommend at 150 pounds
about five foot nine what would you
recommend for them
nutritionally to support the body so
they can have healthier skin
okay well again give you all the bad
stuff no fried foods no processed Meats
no oils or glutens the wheat and brown
oats no buckwheat no sugar no carbonated
drinks even the diet drinks and and the
carbonate water gotta go and then at 100
um
150 pounds 150 pounds let's go with two
healthy brain and heart packs per month
the full load something twice a day two
bottles a month of the MSM saying take
three of breakfast three lunch or dinner
time they're going to support and
promote maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
which includes the skin
because your skin
is like eighty percent or more
connective tissue
some various players but it's connective
tissue okay and so you need you need
these nutrients that support maintenance
repair connective tissue
and uh let's see here
[Music]
um
I I also like the uh here see here Hair
Skin and Nails three of those twice a
day per 100 pounds of body weight okay
they're small bottles you need to get a
couple of those bottles each month the
Hair Skin and nails
and I also like
the rebounder sports drink has 100
nutrients in it okay 75 minerals and uh
25 vitamins amino acids and so you could
have two doses a day of your rebound
sports drink in addition to your two
doses of your 90 essential nutrients and
stay away from the bad stuff to maximize
absorption and relieve inflammation
the odds are you're going to get some
positive results
all right well Dr Wallach I'm first I'm
working on my first dose of rebound here
so usually one one is is very satisfying
refreshing keep you going energizing
because of the vitamins that are in
there and the minerals minerals minerals
are energizing too
some people don't realize that
you know minerals are electrolytes or
many of them what carries what carries
oxygen in your body
the blood
and what part of the blood carries the
oxygen
red blood cells
and what part of the red blood cells
carries oxygen
is it the plasma hemoglobin
the hemoglobin there we go and what what
is hemoglobin made out of
there's a lot that goes into chemo iron
well iron is the first thing I ever
thought of but I
say mineral they're testing me would you
look at that no I'm not testing you I'm
kind of leading you through this because
this is so simple I mean even you know a
fourth grader you know what what is a
red blood cell made out of boy you have
iron in there
how come those kids know that well
they're taught that you know you need
iron to make good red blood cells
this is not difficult
it is not difficult Dr Wallach and I
wish that school's taught
stuff like this like they used to now
not quite so much but I love the fact
that we as parents can introduce
additional information to our children
to help Elevate their learning and to
get them on a track that is more focused
to how the body and nature really work
within this world Dr Wallach yeah we
want them to thrive we want them to
thrive and as they become old enough to
be parents we want not only them to
thrive but they're offering to thrive
and
it takes an enormous amount
of nutrition to pull that off okay and
we're talking about again 60 60 minerals
16 vitamins 12 and Three fatty acids
two or three times a day
okay this is this isn't just
you do this on the holidays
this is two or three times every day
okay if you're going to keep ahead of
the bad guys and you know including
breakdown of tissues and so forth
um you need to stay ahead of all this
negative stuff and which means you've
got to take in all the good stuff
and I you know
um kind of being a farm boy we always
like to say okay well as a veterinarians
telling us to give
um
a cup of these Alfalfa pellets to these
calves with all the vitamins minerals in
them I'm going to give two cups to the
calves
okay because I don't want any messing
around here I want to make sure uh I'd
rather have that calf urinate out some
extra vitamins and minerals than to be
short
right
absolutely absolutely and Dr Wallach I
just glanced over at our chat now if I
would have been paying attention to the
chat I would have known the answers to
your questions because we have a really
smart audience with us today with the
hemoglobin and the iron and all that
good stuff so I just want to do a shout
out and to Applause and congratulations
to our audience that we have here with
us in the zoom
um as they're answering these questions
so good job everybody and if you're out
in the world somewhere not with us here
on the zoom and you would like to join
us sometime on our Zoom or every day we
have people that join us every day
Monday through Friday from 12 to 12 50
p.m Pacific time here on daily with Doc
by going to daily with Doc zoom.com now
folks if you were invited by somebody
very specific make sure that you get
back with them tell them thank you for
sharing this program with you and if you
have any questions in regards to what's
going to be the best fit for you then
make sure that you ask that individual
that share this program with you and
said hey do you know what Dr Wallach
might recommend for me if they don't you
can always go to our website or go to
one of our channels and do a search
through our content and look for those
specific things that you might be
wanting to address within your own
health and you will find information
coming directly from Dr Wallach on what
you can do to help yourself and then
take that information to the person that
shared this program with you if there's
nobody to think then you are more than
welcome to give us a call here on daily
with Doc I have an amazing call team at
855 five nine four nine three three
seven seven that's eight five five nine
four nine three three seven seven we
also have our website with a contact
option go to the contact option you can
submit an email or we can if you sign up
for our newsletter we also have a block
there where you can submit your
questions for Dr Wallach which we have
many questions coming in Dr Wallach and
I know that two of our co-hosts here
have their hand up with questions from
some of their clients or some of these
questions that are coming in
so let's go ahead and jump on into
question stock you ready yep
all right let's first go with Marilyn
Maryland go ahead and unmute yourself
and what questions do you have for Dr
Wallach today actually I have two test
personal testimonials that I want to
cite
and what happened today
my husband's had a stroke for three
years for three years
and the only thing different I take all
the protocols is the last month I mean
giving him additional niacin and I've
been learning through this program and
through Dr Wallach that it's the
precursor for all your neurological
functions
and since he had a stroke that's
something he really needs
well he wouldn't take it he was Furious
because of the niacin flush he was
getting super super red and hot and
itchy well that Dr Wallach said that
means he needs it all the more
so I thought well how am I going to get
him to take it so I started to put a
tablet of niacin in some water dissolved
it so he drinks now that water
throughout the day so he's getting his
niacin and today he gets up out of bed
and he normally can just barely get to
the wheelchair
he actually stood up straight
and made a 360 and backed into the
wheelchair from the bed and I'm looking
at him and I'm like my mouse dropped
open and I said
oh my gosh what did you just do and he
says he says I don't know I just felt
like doing it
so I think the niacin is making some
neurological connection for him
okay so that was my one testimonial then
the other one is my skin has been
reversing
it is just it's like the Fountain of
Youth and it's because of this protocol
now I've also I've been increasing a lot
the Beyonce and tangerine and the after
effects I take extra like I take you in
an extra bottle of minerals the more I
take the better my skin gets and I've
also been increasing collagen
and this is daily
then I take um youngevity's uh vitamin
fatty vitamin C
I put it over my whole body to absorb
anything I want to take extra into the
body because you have to have a fatty
instead of the water soluble and I've
been splashing copper
on top of the fatty vitamin C and then
I've been consuming dark chocolate I
found out the auric score is like 8 000
if the cocoa is 70 or higher
and then I've also one other thing I've
been taking is youngevity's HTH complex
which helps increase melatonin in the
body which is the number one free
radical fighting molecule in the body
for fighting free radicals and the skin
is just it's just unbelievable I have
people come up to me and saying what are
you doing you look you're you look so
much younger and this is even in the
last month so I've been doing those five
things
and it's just been phenomenal so I I
thank you Dr Wallach I mean I just I
used to have to acne I had terrible acne
because I H it was I had sugar I
consumed I could eat anything I I was
from from a well-to-do upper middle
class family I couldn't eat anything but
I ate consumed sugar and no one told me
but now I don't have any acne I haven't
had any in years but Dr wallach's
protocols I thank you I really do well
thank you for sharing your story it's a
beautiful story and beautiful skin thank
you absolutely thank you awesome thank
you so much Marilyn for that those two
testimonials and that would be the
niacin plus I believe that she is
mentioning in regards to adding into her
husband's protocol
um that's absolutely fantastic fantastic
I'm happy for James as well let's go to
Sherry Sherry go ahead and unmute
yourself
thank you very much doc I have a couple
of questions for you today and I loved
Marilyn's testimonial we could all give
our own personal testimonies because
we've all been so blessed by your work
the first is a male he's 72 years old 5
foot 11
230 pounds he has severe back pain he
cannot stand up for very long his
doctors have run every test possible and
they cannot find anything what can we do
for him
okay you need to ask him how many times
he wakes up at night to urinate
once three times five times
because it could be his skull squeezing
the spinal cord
okay his spinal cord is formed in the
brain comes out of the back of the skull
okay you get that book and the CD set in
the book it's all in your head I love
that page where it has a picture of the
brain and the spinal cord going down
towards splits to sciatica it's a sacrum
right left side but when this when the
you have obviously approaches the skull
squeezing the spinal cord up here you're
getting all this stuff going on south of
there okay and so this is very very
telling okay and so again you need the
200 plus pounds I'd have them take um
get rid of all the bad foods no fried
food no processed meat so oils no gluten
so eaten by Rhino sugar no carbonated
drinks you know the diet drinks got to
go and and also carbonated water got to
go and then I would take two healthy
brain and hard pasture a month to follow
what I was saying twice a day two
bottles a month of the MSM so he can
take um uh three brackets straight lunch
or dinner time that's going to help
rebuild cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue disc between the
vertebrae bone rate from itself
including the skull and the vertebrae
and the lower back and and so forth and
um let's see here also he needs the
rebound or sport strength of two there's
230 something pounds uh he can take um
two doses of the rebound today okay and
that's gonna give them more minerals all
right and more energy and so forth and
let's start there
okay
thank you the second is a female 62
years old
she's five foot seven
weighs 125 pounds very active is uh
teaches dance as well as plays
pickleball she would die she was
diagnosed with ulcerative proctitis
what she's taking
ulcerative proctitis
and the rectum ulcerated rectum
I looked it up that's what it said okay
ulcerated
no no prostate
she's died
on me she takes oral medication uh she
didn't say what it was but she also
takes Miralax two times a day for
chronic constipation okay let's just
stop there for a minute okay okay
um please get rid of all the bad stuff
we've gone over that so many times here
quickly no fried food no process means
no oils or glutens and Wheaton by rhinos
no buckwheats uh no sugar no carbon or
drinks even the diet drinks got to go in
carbonated water and we do have the book
Dr Wallace cooking without the bad foods
it has a good food bad food list in
there and 300 pages of safe recipes and
so on like cooking out the bad foods and
then
125 pounds
we want her to have
um one healthy branded hard pack per
month uh half a dose of everything twice
a day one bottle a month of the MSM so
you can take three breakfasts three
dinner time to support promote Mains
repair cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebrate bone makes one of the self
then she also needs one dose at least a
rebound or sport strength during the day
for energy and more minerals and so on
okay and
um
let's let's go there okay okay thank you
so much you have pain if she has pain
you know her neck or her back we do have
the CM cream where she can apply to
those painful areas and she'll get
anywhere from three to five hours of
pain relief okay
thank you very much
very much okay you bet
all right thank you Sherry for bringing
those questions and Dr Wallach Charlotte
here with us has a question she wants to
know if you would recommend going to a
chiropractor that does neck adjustments
to help with spinal pinching or the
osteoporosis of the brain
so that would be awesome process of the
skull yeah
and of course that can give some
temporary relief
but doing
a manipulation doesn't regrow
the skull it requires the nutrients okay
and again we're looking at per 100
pounds of body weight one Health brain
and heart pack one bottle a month of the
MSM collagen peptides
um
uh scoop of that with the morning drinks
for the evening drink
and they can do if she had good
insurance she'd get an MRI not an x-ray
but an MRI there's no radiation and you
know you get that book in the CD uh it's
all in your head
page number six in the front it's got
two pictures one of a normal skull which
is a quarter of an inch thick there you
go at the top
and the bottom one is the skull
osteoporosis it's an inch and a half to
two inches thick and that's not bone
that's connective tissue the scar tissue
because the bone is gone okay and you
can see her that'll be squeezing you can
flip over the next page I think it is
or a picture uh let's flip it to another
page another flip another page
I'll show that I want to show this the
brain the skull the brain and the spinal
cord
okay it's in there
this one there you go and you can see
everything below the chin
okay you got stuff going on in the neck
okay in the back getting up at night to
urinate five or eight or ten times uh
balance problems ringing in the ears all
this stuff the regular heartbeat it's
all due to the skull squeezing the 12
pairs of cranial nerves and the spinal
cord okay and doctors didn't know
anything about this and so this is why
we wrote the book and have the CD so
this is a compilation between Dr Milan
uh Rebecca and myself
we have the book we have the CD it's a
set and it covers about 135 different
diseases and symptoms that you get when
you have osteoporosis of the skull okay
and so doctors know nothing about this
they do not get taught this in school I
was kind of amazed when I was doing all
these autopsies
I'm seeing the results on the autopsy
table
but when you look at the clinical
records that came along with the body
they never mentioned anything about what
was going on in those areas so that
means they they have no earthly idea
what's going on
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach and we're just gonna Buzz
through some of these questions that are
coming in we have Ann and Ann's question
oops
starts out last week he recommended my
husband and go
um up his glucogel to five three times a
day
um and MSM three three times a day or
his arthritis I'm happy to report that
he's feeling great and as he said this
stuff really works so maybe it's to take
care of my cranky knees how much
glucogel and MSM would somebody who is
five foot six and
130 pounds take if with in addition to
the brain and heart pack
how much MSM would you recommend for
Anne at 130 pounds Dr Wallach and
glucogel well she's right that cusp if
she has symptoms I'd go with two bottles
of MSM so you could take three breakfast
food lunch at dinner time
okay and um you want to kind of err on
the side of a little bit too much as
opposed to not enough
okay and the glucogel
um
you can also take two or three of those
twice a day that was our original
collagen products okay there's a glucose
gel we added that to our Healthy Start
pack and it became the healthy Bone and
Joint pack for Theo Ratliff okay so
that's where that came from
now glucogel is my friend Dr Wallach
that's what I started with as well in
addition to the 90 essential nutrients
and
all the nutrition that's found in the
Pink Pack Plus
which has the liquid nutrition including
the glucogel so I absolutely love
glucogel and Keith has a question here
so Keith is six foot
207 pounds
um he never wakes up during the night to
urinate
in 2019 he had his prostate removed by
robotic assisted surgery
there was some nerve damage during the
procedure uh post-op PSA result test
results have been undetectable until
recently the tests results in March of
23 at a 0.113
August was .222 this caused the decline
for life insurance policy
so what can be done Dr Wallach when
you've got a PSA that's elevating and no
prostate
with nerve damage
well
um there may be a little piece of
prostate gland that was left behind
okay
and so that's not unusual and they start
doing the surgery and stuff like that so
just whack things out and maybe leave a
piece of size of a diamond or something
like that so that's all possible okay
anyway 207 pounds uh needs to
um take two of the health brain and hard
packs for a month full go through
everything twice a day I'd get to two
bottles a month the MSM so you take
three breakfast three lunch at dinner
time I also want to take the
um rebound or his first drink you could
take two doses of that a day also the
anti-inflammatory stuff
um would would be good
um when we're talking about things like
um
oh
what
would you what would you recommend for
anti-inflammation
well the MSM is really good for
anti-inflammation essential fatty acids
help with anti-inflammation
um we've got the stay restored from the
stay natural line that has herbs in
there that contribute to helping with
the inflammation
um even well big thing let's go with a
couple of doses a day of the stairy
store okay and um the odds are there's a
little piece of prostate left in there
okay
and um that's not unusual and they're
doing surgery they're in a hurry and
whack whack whacking they're out of
there and they they leave a little piece
and that's what goes on
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach and let's see what is our time
cheery has a question here yep it is
time unfortunately folks we did not get
to all the questions we thank you so
much Dr Wallach as I know you have to
get to your next program
um thank you everybody for joining us
here on daily with Doc my name is Becca
dukes and if I could get all of my
co-hosts on with me
um I do know some of the people that are
asking questions I will make sure that
we get answers to those questions to you
and folks if you would like to send in
your questions
via email please do so go to daily
withdoc.com use that contact option and
we'll be able to get response to you
from either myself or one of my co-hosts
based on Dr wallach's recommendations if
you've got some unique things going on
we always ask Dr Wallach and make sure
that we get what he would recommend it's
not us recommending it's using Dr
wallach's recommendations for people who
have symptoms that match yours from from
the past so
I just want to do a big shout out and
thank you to all of my team and our
black t-shirts where we are rising up
going big to be able to share this
knowledge that we have with others and
this was just one of the friendly
competitions that youngevity offered to
the Distributors the coaches who are
associated with them as we are sharing
youngevity rewards us not only in the
fact that well youngevity doesn't reward
us and the fact that we're able to help
people and just have that joy in it but
we do get thank you checks and then they
run competitions and we're able to do
the friendly competitions and earn
things like cool t-shirts and trips and
all that good stuff and folks
you know
doing something that you enjoy
and being able to
prosper from that is not a bad thing
especially whenever you're able to yeah
we see it Marilyn go right uh go rising
up and going big
um
but you know trips where we can take
trips with our family and we continue to
learn we continue to take the energy
that we get from the nutrition
because it's within us and
then it's just exuberating out from us
and we just all get together and have a
great time and if that's something that
you think that you might be interested
in being part of we invite you to look
into having your own
like youngevity distributorship folks
it's like having a franchise just
different wording where you can
right make recommendations kid thank you
checks and people are buying from your
own store
instead of going to a big box store that
has inferior products that don't work
that's why supplements get a bad name is
because you just buy all these things
really cheap
and they're not in a form that the body
can actually use nor are they Blended so
that they work together
and I love the fact that youngevity has
taken the guesswork out of it Dr Wallach
was his formulations that are offered
through youngevity
um they do it in a way that they
synergistically work together in a form
that the body can actually absorb
because
you get something in the body that the
body can't absorb or in the wrong form
it can be toxic yes
but that's where all of the science and
the great formulators with youngevity
have taken taken that part that we don't
have to worry about out so I love it
I've benefited from it I know my
co-hosts have benefited from it and
today we have on with us Ruth Ellen
Sanchez my executive production manager
as she does all these things in the
background folks more than more than
most of us know and making sure that
everything is running smoothly we have
Albert who is joining us from South
Africa and just hoping to spread the
news down farther south you know you say
down under you think Australia but when
I say down south I mean South Africa
folks so thank you so much Albert as you
are helping let people in and keep an
eye on the chat we have Marilyn who we
call Fingers
um who who's doing dictation for us and
taking the recommendations that Dr
Wallach recommends for individuals as
the questions are asked and putting them
in the chat here which is one of the
biggest pluses of being live with us on
daily with Doc zoom.com we have
Sherry who is also keeping an eye on the
chat on the cameras out watching
different platforms and helping to bring
those questions in and we have our
assistant executive production manager
AJ who is getting the message out on
even more and more platforms folks so
that we can meet you where you're at and
make sure that the information is
getting out there and is findable that
was a big thing that we were able to
tackle this past week and making sure
that when people do a search for daily
with Doc or Dr Wallach or daily with Doc
and Becca that they're actually finding
us and not not somebody else but folks
we are a family we work together and we
just invite you to feel the difference
that the 90 essential nutrients can make
these are the nutrients that Dr Wallach
has been forming instrumental in
formulating not just some minerals off
the sh off the counter because they're
not created the same
come and feel the difference my name is
Becca Dukes as the hostess of this
program
thank you for investing your time into
yourself and we invite you to share this
information with somebody you know and
care about
until next time bye for now
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]